good morning as was said my name is
Howard Fineman I'm a political
correspondent with Newsweek magazine and
I also report for NBC News and MSNBC out
of Washington based in Washington but
the reason I'm here is that I'm a native
Pittsburgher and I have lived both
personally and at a distance and
journalistically through the transition
the economic transition of Pittsburgh
excuse me which is the reason why you're
here
the story of Pittsburgh is a story of
renewal and I'm a reporter and I'm a
skeptic by nature and since I don't
actually live in the city I can have
some distance on it and I can tell you
as America looks to the 21st century and
as it welcomes the economic and
political leaders of the world
pittsburgh has a story that needs to be
known because it's a story of America's
hope economically and politically for
that matter in the 21st century this was
an industrial city heavy industrial city
this was a city where when my
grandmother and mother went shopping
when my grandmother when my mother was a
girl used to take with them on their
shopping visits to downtown Pittsburgh a
change of blouse and a washcloth with
them because the pollution in the air
from the open hearth steel mills was so
intensive that they couldn't get through
the day and stay clean
that was the Pittsburgh of the 20s and
30s and that was a Pittsburgh that
existed up until the 1980s that city is
gone and what has replaced it through a
lot of pain
turmoil is a new city based on the
economies of the future those in
economies include entertainment and
tourism you may have heard of a football
team called the Pittsburgh Steelers
they're a global commodity it's based on
financial services banks like PNC and
we'll even count Bank of New York Mellon
and green technologies ironically the
city of Pittsburgh was one of the first
to begin to clean up its own air and
water installing smoke control in late
40s and from that tiny base a great
green technology has grown up but the
key right now to Pittsburgh's future and
in many ways to America's future are to
technologies and to sectors that are
represented here the shorthand for them
is Ed's and meds and we have the leader
the leaders of the Ed's and meds sectors
here they overlap in the synergies
between them are yet another reason why
Pittsburgh is such a success story that
Barack Obama wants to show to the world
at a point where frankly America's
economic leadership on the planet is not
only called into question but was more
necessary than ever so here are the
people that I want to introduce to you
from my immediate left Jared Cohen who's
the president of Carnegie Mellon
University one of the great research
universities in the world immediately
next to him is chancellor mark
Nordenberg the Chancellor of the
University of Pittsburgh also one of the
great research universities in the world
and let me pause right here to say that
there very few places in America if not
the world where two such great
universities are literally right next
door to each other the only other one I
can think of is a city near Boston
called Cambridge Massachusetts
you know usually think of Pittsburgh in
Cambridge Massachusetts in the same
mental breadth
get used to it and taking advantage of
and building on the great resources of
the universities here plus Pittsburgh's
great tradition of medical care is
Geoffrey romoff who is the president and
CEO CEO that is of UPMC UPMC has its
roots in the university of pittsburgh
medical center but has become one of the
largest healthcare providers in the
country if not the world these are great
leaders and innovators and I wanted to
present them to you this morning and ask
them some questions this is not Meet the
Press but let me start with with the
with a tough one if I could for
president Cohen of CMU you've had great
success but right now the United States
might be limited somewhat in terms of
research money in terms of resources to
make sure that the successes that
pittsburgh has made can be maintained in
the future what is what is CMU doing to
keep the lead that it's fought so hard
to get I thought mark and Jeff ready to
get the hard question I was supposed to
get the softballs it's a great question
Howard before I answer it though let me
welcome you home thank you and welcome
all of our visitors from around the
world this is a very very exciting week
for Pittsburgh and a well-deserved week
of attention on Pittsburgh for all the
reasons you said our it is a great story
and it'll be wonderful to have a chance
to tell it in kurta game Ellen's case
it's interesting first of all we have to
realize that Carnegie Mellon's history
in a lot of ways mirrors the history of
Pittsburgh and when I say that I mean we
started as a trade school basically a
century ago
that's what Andrew Carnegie had in mind
and we've evolved over those years and
especially over the last three or four
years 30 or 40 years into one of the
leading global research universities as
you
said what we've been doing to solidify
our gains are a couple of things one is
to become truly global you'll you'll be
hearing about this also from my
colleagues who are doing similar things
but we decided about a decade ago that
becoming truly global would be a key
part of our future and that's meant a
couple of things one is being global
here in Pittsburgh in terms of the
composition of our student body and our
faculty but it is also meant going out
into the world and we now have campuses
in Australia in Qatar and programs in
many countries in Europe and in Asia and
we continue to expand this is I think
keen only because the world is so
globally connected but frankly what has
been a world dominated by American
wealth and concentrations of wealth it's
gonna be a world where that distribution
is much flatter than it has been we want
to be where the wealth creation is going
on to be part of them the second thing
we're doing is to diversify our sources
of income one of those is by being
global but another is to do as much as
we can to create ties to corporations
both those that are global themselves
and those which are here in Pittsburgh
and in a lot of cases that's meant
bringing them to Pittsburgh one of our
great successes in the last few years
has been attracting companies like Intel
Apple Google and recently Disney to work
with our people that work in
entertainment technology so those are
the things that we're doing and I think
universities research university to be
successful have to do to continue to
succeed by the way I would suggest to
those of you who are visiting from
elsewhere who want to see what I'm
talking about to go out to the Pitt and
CMU campuses the Pitt campuses right
here CMU is just right up forbes and v
they're they're really remarkable and in
in Chancellor Nordenberg I wanted to ask
you
about pit both my parents were oral um
alumni of University of Pittsburgh if
you haven't seen it you've got to see
the world's tallest gothic spire which
to me is a symbol of Pitt and the beacon
that it is to the people of the city I
guess my question for you mr. mr.
Chancellor is how do you balance your
commitment to being a Pittsburgh
institution I mean after all it says
University of Pittsburgh
how do you balance that with a a world
role which I know you're playing
increasingly especially I would say in
such fields as medical technology and so
forth well we never have felt that there
was anything inconsistent between having
a home region as you say we are the
University of Pittsburgh we always will
draw our single largest group of
students from this region we always will
place our single largest group of
graduates in this region but to have
programs that are world-class in terms
of their quality and impact in what we
find today on the educational front in
particular is an increasing ability to
keep the very best students from this
region here in this region for their
undergraduate and graduate education an
ability to reach out to all corners of
this country and beyond to pull in other
students who make the student body more
diverse and more interesting and I think
one of the things that is telling in all
of our organizations is the ability that
exists today to reach out to recruit
faculty and physician talent we recruit
from the very best places in this
country and beyond and so you know Jonas
Salk developed his vaccine here in
Pittsburgh but the development of that
vaccine was a worldwide victory we just
don't see anything incompatible with
those roles
Jeffrey Romo off the president and CEO
of UPMC let me ask you what may sound
like a silly question but could you PMZ
it could you PMC exist anywhere else but
here that's a silly question that's a
very good question it's a very
insightful question I would proudly say
that UPMC doesn't exist anywhere else
but here which is evidence enough and I
think one of the reasons for that which
i think is they follow up but you want
to hear about is that Pittsburgh
historically in every sector has been
full of natural resources which begged
to be mined and begged to be put
together made into something better and
thereby be used to the advantage of the
region and ultimately to the advantage
of the world in the health care sector
in Pittsburgh we had as virtually almost
every major city in the country we had a
diffuse system a system of small
community hospitals a system of somewhat
related university related hospitals but
really weren't intimately tied to the
universities into research we had just a
bunch of things that were not put
together in any coherent fashion and to
the credit of the leadership of this
community particularly the boards of
these hospitals the board's ultimately
of UPMC the board of the University of
Pittsburgh we were able to voluntarily
come together where parts each one of
these organizations gave up some of
their autonomy to create something that
had
the breadth and depth and largeness of a
UPMC which is now fifty thousand
employees eight billion dollars a year
in expenditures and increasingly a
global health enterprise it's a it's a
if I can say it's a it's a remarkable
thing because as I've watched it at a
distance
UPMC has grown up out of what began as
the university based culture at the
University of Pittsburgh Medical Center
which was always very highly regarded as
a Medical Center I think that Cleveland
Minneapolis New York you know LA
Pittsburgh was always in that ball game
in terms of hospitals in health care but
it was through the imagination and the
vision and I and I guess the cooperation
of people up here among others that they
began to see there was a better way to
do it and you could take the research
from the University and apply it more
broadly and you could use business
management practices to try to
rationalize the care this isn't exactly
why we're here
but right now back in Washington there's
a huge debate going on about health care
and how to rationally and humanely
provide health care to all Americans
those foreign journalists who are here
maybe be stunned to be reminded that in
the United States everybody isn't
guaranteed health care at least directly
we're having a huge argument about that
and now that I think of it these
gentlemen here are part of the part of
the answer I think to to our to our
situation
let me ask all of you and anyone can
answer who wants another thing that's
always been strong in Pittsburgh has
been in the Pittsburgh area has been
elementary and secondary education
because these systems rest atop what has
always been in Pittsburgh a really
terrific local elementary and secondary
education system I'm curious how you
view it right now in the city in the
county
what strides are they making and
what are you doing to help make sure
that that that base helps Pittsburgh
thrive in the 21st century anybody wants
well take a look at that maybe if I can
start on that because UPMC is
exceptionally proud of our contribution
which was not a natural contribution
which my colleagues at CMU and Pitt can
do far more effectively but UPMC made a
hundred million dollar commitment
stimulated by the Pittsburgh Board of
Education to basically assure that at
the secondary school level that students
who are educated in the Pittsburgh
school system can receive scholarships
that will allow them to go to any
college or university or Community
College in all of Pennsylvania this and
it became a matching program we gave ten
million dollars up front and the other
ninety million has to be matched about
one and a half times in order to to make
it effective but this has a profound
effect because the school system in
Pittsburgh the inner-city in Pittsburgh
has progressively as so many inner
cities converted to being the majority
of the students a minority with the out
migration to the suburbs so this became
an impetus to support the school systems
to have parents want to come and stay in
the city and thereby we contribute to
the tax base and for us once again to be
able to be in a position to feed our
spectacular universities and colleges
with excellent people from the region
who are committed familywize to
pittsburgh and as you know so well once
you're a Pittsburgher you always love to
come home you know all of us have been
in our positions for a comparatively
long period of mind and sustained
efforts probably have contributed to
whatever successes we have enjoyed
Geoffrey and I have been here a bit
longer than Jerry has been and I think
each of us go back to the
days when the quality of the Pittsburgh
Public Schools was one of the big
community assets when you were
attempting to recruit faculty members
for example the existence of a public
system of that quality was one of the
things that could tip the balance in
being successful in your effort or not
we are all working in our own ways to
try to restore the quality of the
Pittsburgh Public Schools overall to the
days when Taylor Allderdice was
recognized as one of the finest public
high schools in the country
what the UPMC did by becoming the
principal funder of the Pittsburgh
Promise really is incredible I don't
know of that kind of community
investment in any other place and as
jeff indicated really Jerry and I
through our university programs are in a
position to provide help of other types
so we do have a center for urban
education in the University of
Pittsburgh and are working hard not only
with the Pittsburgh Public Schools but
places like Wilkinsburg as well and I
know that Carnegie Mellon has special
contributions that it's making of that
type as well you want to mention
anything yeah I would like to add one
thing but let me also second Mark's
comment you PMC's announcement of its
commitment to the promise was absolutely
stunning stunning in in every way and I
think was just an act of tremendous
leadership personal and institutional by
you
UPMC and Jeff and something for which
we're all very grateful universe
University of Pittsburgh has real
strengths that go directly to the
educational challenges of the Pittsburgh
Public School System occurring in
melon's case we do many many things
many of them in the form of volunteerism
by our students in faculty and it has
real impact the other thing we do is to
bring to bear our technology strengths
and Carnegie Mellon has emerged as a
real leader in technology based
education especially computer-based
tutors for mathematics which is having a
very large impact around the country and
increasing around the morning both at
the middle school and high school level
and now at the college level and I think
very significantly and something I hope
will have a chance to come back to a
major thing we do we do in collaboration
University of Pittsburgh together we won
one of the first major grants for the
National Science Foundation to create a
so-called science a warning center
science what's a science of learning
sign that learning center and it brings
together our strength and cognitive
science and computer science with Pitts
great strengths in education research
and the collaboration is very powerful
the Pittsburgh public school systems
certainly benefits from that but this
has implications for education wherever
it happens well you have to take what I
say with a grain of salt because even
though I'm a they dyed-in-the-wool
journalist I'm also a Pittsburgh ER so
be cautious but the kind of
collaboration that you're seeing the
kind of commitment to the city and by
city I mean this region is is is not
unusual in America because America
believe it or not is still a ground up
country from the ground up but I've been
in every state in the Union but one and
reported from all of them and written
about them and there's no place no city
that I know of that maintains a sense of
civic commitment greater than this city
does and it relates to the election of
Barack Obama in this sense Barack Obama
was a Democrat from a big northern city
Chicago and if you know a little
american political history you know how
unusual that is since jack kennedy who
arguably was from boston the democrats
never
since a president other than one from a
small southern town Lyndon Johnson Jimmy
Carter and Bill Clinton Barack Obama is
a city guy he's an urban guy and in the
21st century cities are where the action
is the big global cities does Pittsburgh
have the size of London Paris New York
Rio Buenos Aires Shanghai you know etc
Tokyo etc no but there's no place where
pound for pound is the commitment to
these kinds of cutting-edge things
greater in my view than here and that's
that's what you're that's what you're
seeing this is a a really open-ended
question I want each of you to tell me
or tell them what's the most important
thing about your institution that you're
guessing they don't know that they need
to know and I'll take it in reverse
order Jeff you go first
I'm not sure there's anything that they
don't know about UPMC but having said
that I think the most essential
characteristic of UPMC which is
particularly important today
particularly important today in
Pittsburgh particularly important given
the adversarial climate with a recession
with health reform and the uncertainty
it's very important but it's an
uncertain situation for us is our
capacity to change and to morph and to
be opportunistic no matter how
challenging the circumstances are UPMC
despite its largeness despite its the
fact that it does or seeks to do so many
things has the capacity to mobilize
itself with the Faculty of the
University of Pittsburgh schools of the
Health Sciences with our staff with our
20 hospitals with our international per
with a high-tech and relationships with
our collaboration with the CMU and
basically direct sometimes in a
laser-like way what we want to do to be
or seek to be in the right place at the
right time
a very small example well it's not that
small but an appropriate example is that
right now the president is talking about
the need for digitalising healthcare as
one of the linchpins of health reform
and making health care much more
efficient and more cost effective down
the road apiece you will see the new
Children's Hospital of Pittsburgh of
UPMC which is a research center as well
as a brand new Children's Hospital which
is a hundred percent digitalize and we
started this about six or seven years
somewhat before it was fashionable to do
that and built on top of that or
underneath it a billion dollar
investment in bringing all of UPMC up to
being at the cutting edge of
digitalization we also did this in
collaboration with our far more
experienced and far more sophisticated
colleagues over Carnegie Mellon let me
say in 2000 I think it was our Board of
Trustees issued a public statement of
aspiration and said that we would
clearly and convincingly demonstrate
that the University of Pittsburgh was
one of the finest most productive
universities in the world
that has been our goal ever since
I think people who are knowledgeable are
surprised that we have made as much
progress toward that goal in a
compressed period of time as we have our
people tend to view universities as
institutions that are so large and
unmanageable
to change direction even slightly work
to pick up speed by a couple of miles is
an almost impossible task I don't think
that that is the case if it whether
you're looking at a near tripling of
undergraduate applications a move from
kind of top 15 the top five in terms of
NIH funding things are moving well on
every front but I do want to use this
opportunity to also say that we really
don't think of ourselves as unde
attached particularly from the
institutions represented on either side
of me when you look at Jeff and Jerry
and me you probably would not find three
guys who are more competitive but we
also are good collaborators and we know
that in this day and age you really do
need to define competition in a
different way it can't be the hospital's
against the health science schools you
can't be pet looking enviously across
Junction Hollow
at Carnegie Mellon we really are in it
together
I think someone once said if you've seen
one academic Medical Center you've seen
one academic Medical Center in terms of
organization and structure certainly
that would be true of the relationship
between UPMC and the University there is
nothing like it and to return to one of
your opening points if I may when Jerry
came to town we actually said here these
two universities sit side by side one
public one private one large one midsize
really complementary academic strengths
and we thought there was only one other
place in the country Cambridge
Massachusetts where you could find the
total academic firepower that you could
find in Oakland and we knew that we
needed to find ways to cooperate and
hard
that power for our own good and for the
good of the community and I think that
is a part of the culture of Pittsburg as
you have described it I think the one
thing that would come as the biggest
surprise to especially international
journalists about Carnegie Mellon is
that we are as strong in the arts as we
are in technology we're probably best
known for our strength in technology but
in fact while we've won 13 Nobel prizes
we've won many more Oscars Tony's and
Emmys and it's it's a wonderful thing
about this university we're a really
small one as Mark said but packed in the
small package is this very different
range of disciplines in which our strong
that is of interest and excitement in of
itself but increasingly through our
collaborative culture of working across
disciplines we're taking advantage of
those twin strengths so the
entertainment Technology Center which
many of you will tour later is a great
example of that bringing together our
School of Drama with our school of
computer science and the other thing I
would mention is just picking up on
Mark's point and I can't his last point
which I can't really add to what it's
bears repeating Carnegie Mellon is by
nature a very collaborative place the
notion and interdisciplinary
collaboration has been with us for at
least 60 years and is really core to our
existence it's how we've been as
successful as we have been despite being
a relative small university but
increasingly that also means
inter-institutional collaboration and
that means what these two institutions
represented up here on the stage that
has been absolutely fundamental to our
success in recent years and I think the
three of us working together has meant
everything to Pittsburg success and
Howard later in the day after a couple
of drinks Jerry will sing and dance
to prove that art point for you know
sickened dance while I solve a complex
manual well I think you I think you
mentioned maybe you've just mentioned it
here I'm having a little hard time
hearing because of the acoustics did you
mention Disney again not my wife
obviously duh you're thinking what is
the Disney Company doing at CMU well
they're putting together their Disney
see it now that I think of it CMU is
Disney East in the sense that you put
together the computer knowledge of
Carnegie Mellon on one side of the
campus with the arts turn you know CMU
has as a fabulous theater arts program
and and and visual arts for that matter
don't forget that Andy Warhol the
globally celebrated artist whose museum
is across the river and for those
foreign journalists who are here
international journalists not foreign we
don't use the word foreign anymore the
international journalists go over to see
the Warhol Museum it's unbelievable
he was from Pittsburgh he graduated in
graphic arts from from what was then
Carnegie Tech when I was a kid we used
to say there were two kinds of people
that Carnegie what was then Carnegie
Tech and I'll demonstrate how old I am
when I say this half the campus had
slide rules on their belts and the other
half were wearing Sirah peas and this is
the 60s and then that that continues to
this day it's really remarkable I have a
theory I which I've never I haven't
mentioned anybody but I will I will
debut right here there's a mythic figure
in the history of Pittsburgh he didn't
really exist
he's the Paul Bunyan of Pittsburgh for
those of you who don't know who Paul
Bunyan was he was a mythic man of the
north the great great logger and
frontiersman in Pittsburgh we had a
mythic steelworker
didn't really exist
his name was Joe magic and he ate ingots
of steel for breakfast and we used to
sing songs about Joe mazzaroth growing
up in the Pittsburgh schools if you can
believe it well Joe magic is gone but I
think among these three people if you
put together the robotics studies that
they're doing at CMU which is world
class and the bioengineering and
healthcare stuff they're doing across
the board at Pitt and UPMC etc that we
could make here in Pittsburgh we could
create an actual biological digitally
created Joe measure act and I think that
should be a goal for all three of you so
how collaborative effort the three of
you together but anyway no do we have
time are we about ready for some
questions here can I just yell over
their very last comment I mean the
visual connection is so powerful I can't
resist so I'm looking at cardio robotics
company founded by my faculty and there
is our professor how are you standing
right now standing up
there's your Joe Masoretic so he's a
roboticist he works with medical people
at Pitt you know and their company is
creating a tiny tiny little robot that's
going to crawl around your heart
yeah well I'm only half joking about
this I think this will be one of the
homes of bio engineering robotics
together yeah I just wanted at a point
that when Jerry said one of the great
surprises to people would be the the
success in the arts at Carnegie Mellon
which is of course splendidly true I
think it relates to a larger issue about
Pittsburgh versus other great cities I
grew up in the Bronx in New York and I
had all the arrogance of a New Yorker
and I was absolutely convinced that not
only Andy Warhol who lived downtown in a
loft someplace but all of jazz and all
of arts were invented in New York
and of course I was surprised as I
sometimes think many Pittsburghers are
surprised to find out that most of what
at least I cherished as a New Yorker was
indeed invented here in Pittsburgh
school and and if if we in Pittsburgh
had a little bit more I will go to the
extreme of arrogance but a little bit
more of the pride and understanding of
what we have here and what we always
have here had here not just what my
colleagues and I hope to bring in the
city of the future I think we would at
least enjoy it a little bit more yeah I
think that's true and I think I think
that to attract world-class talent to a
city like Pittsburgh
you need not only the educational
institutions for children you need not
only the great universities and the
great employers like we have represented
here you need a vibrant arts scene in a
cultural scene and you may be surprised
those of you who are from elsewhere
to sample some of that around the city
great arts tradition great music
tradition great theater tradition
terrific public institutions and
creative and creative people in all
communities I mean a lot of the jazz a
lot of a lot of American jazz I wouldn't
say was invented but perfected in
Pittsburgh on the Hill District which is
just a couple miles from here a lot of
great artists not only Warhol but Mary
Cassatt is one name that comes to mind a
lot of great writers historians poets
that's true of any American city but I
think Pittsburghers are very unassuming
and sometimes they're even dare I say it
down on their town since I don't live
here anymore I've become something of a
professional Pittsburgh town crier
everywhere I go and I'm always proud to
do it and I might also say that sports
matters here but it matters not just for
the sports of it and not just for the
community pride of it but for the hard
work of it Pittsburgh is not a place
Pittsburgh is not a place
that likes show-offs
Pittsburgh is not a place that likes
people who are always Tooting their own
horn Pittsburgh is very unlike New York
in that respect and they appreciate hard
work and teamwork which a team like the
Steelers or the Penguins in hockey and
in the old days the Pirates used to used
to show and to my way of thinking mike
tomlin who is the coach of the
Pittsburgh Steelers is a perfect model
for quality and cutting-edge leadership
in the city
I believe he's sending his kids to the
Pittsburgh Public Schools from not
mistaken he lives in the city doesn't
live in a big fancy house in the suburb
and my prized possession is a black and
gold t-shirt with the silhouette of Mike
Tomlin on it that says yes we can people
do a double-take when they see it do we
have time for a few questions okay five
minutes okay okay let's see let me start
with this one
what did Pittsburgh do better than
Cleveland Detroit etc why has Pittsburgh
succeeded so far and this is from
Adrienne from the German media any of
you want to take we have a Cleveland
native Cleveland the Cleveland refugee
here we go
I thought we would get all the way
through this without my Cleveland roots
coming to the fore I grew up in
Cleveland made the mistake of arriving
here and the first thing saying you can
take the boy out of Cleveland but you
can't take the Browns out of the boy
so last time I said that publicly until
now and the international press you will
beat me up actually the big
distinguishing feature of Pittsburgh
compared to Cleveland and Detroit is the
as it med sector now Detroit for
whatever reason has never had a great
research university and maybe it's
because University of Michigan is close
enough that the city couldn't justify
within the city itself Cleveland I know
better and they have no such excuse they
have Case Western Reserve University in
the Cleveland Clinic and I'll let others
try to detect this and you could pursue
this further in Cleveland but they never
figured out how to work together quite
the opposite
they've really kind of been at
loggerheads for many many years
and they've created they've had many
attempts to getting together and it just
hasn't worked and I think that's all I
should say about it it's in stark
contrast to what you find here of a
private university working very
comfortably with a public university and
both of us working it early with and
very productively with our major Medical
Center well I would say because Gerry
and I actually have talked about this
and we have said that if you went back
to the days now becoming more and more
remote that we were college-age
ourselves you wouldn't have seen that
kind of difference between Pittsburgh
and Cleveland Cleveland did have case
and it had Western reserved and it had
the Cleveland Clinic and Pittsburgh had
Carnegie Tech and the University of
Pittsburgh and a collection of hospitals
that later became the UPMC and so at
some point along the way leadership was
provided that first I think propelled
the individual institutions ahead of
some of their competitors in other
regions
and then the reaching out and the
partnering began that made the sum
greater than they are the whole greater
than the sum of its parts the only thing
I would add is that propose there's an
article in today's Detroit Free Press
the only reason I read it is my
colleagues sent it to me because it's
about Pittsburgh and about UPMC in about
the g20 the sum and substance of the
Detroit perspective on Pittsburgh is
would it be that we could have done what
you did in Pittsburgh and the Detroit
Free Press at least this authors and
this journalists perspective was unlike
Detroit Pittsburgh was not a one-trick
horse and it had the diversity it had
many many things it was doing
simultaneously when a very very
important one the smokestack industries
fell away the rest continued with the
same kind of affinity for success in
hard work sure do we have time frame to
pursue this a little bit further sure I
think we have a few minutes but without
attempting to make any comparisons into
other cities but speaking as someone who
didn't grow up here and it's been here
now for 12 plus years I I have to say
that certainly one of the great
characteristics of Pittsburgh which has
allowed it to succeed is the the people
the the the quality of this place and it
touches on some of the points you were
making our I'm continuously impressed by
this that of course there's the work
ethic which is well known and hard work
serious people that not bothering to
take the time to blow once on horror
just getting on on with it
I I I wasn't here in the early eighties
but just the numbers themselves talk
about an incredible social dislocation
when the number of jobs lost were lost
in those 18 months or two years for any
community still to be around let alone
to be thriving the way this one is 25
years later I think speaks volumes
about the quality and the nature and the
strength of the people in this community
it's quite remarkable and I celebrate
that as an outsider and wonder at it and
Carnegie Mellon frankly benefits from
that and thinks of itself as an
institution with similar characteristics
or hopes it is and this makes a huge
difference a huge difference in ways
that are not easily perceivable in the
healthcare sector now when you think of
great healthcare you want to think of
great healthcare in New York you want to
think of great healthcare in Boston in
other major cities but what you don't
see is the infrastructure of healthcare
the nurses the technicians the people
who do the housekeeping and the cleaning
here in Pittsburgh because the city is a
manageable size because it has a
workforce because you can actually get
to work and live in a four bedroom home
for $80,000 or $100,000 a year you have
a workforce every day that is competent
that is committed that is ethical and
does its job I don't care what you want
to say about the flash of New York or
the flash of a New York doctor the
hospitals can't work the staff can't get
to work they can't afford to live near
work and then once they arrive they're
worrying about when they're going to get
home this is not the way you take care
of other people if you have to be
consumed with taking care of yourself
here in Pittsburgh we're comfortable
with our families we're comfortable in
our environment and we can give much
more to each other and to the
institutional commitments we have well I
guess it poses the question about
whether a city of this size and we're
talking in the city itself of only about
what 300,000 now which is half of what
it was when I was a child in the
metropolitan area of about 1.2 million
which is roughly the same size that it
was 30 40 years ago can a city like that
which actually has some unique
advantages in terms of health care in
terms of research in terms of Education
in terms of manageability livability
affordability can that city play on a
global stage it can it be a global city
of this size can there be a global city
of this size and I think Pittsburgh is
making the argument and I suppose we're
making the argument here this morning to
the world that it not only can be it is
and with that I think I'm going to thank
these wonderful panelists which to whom
you should give a round of applause and
thank you